these guys would be like you're doing
you're doing weddings I'm levitating
that like they're dissing him like he's
like a wedding band guy so you're doing
weddings brah I'm [ __ ] levitation do
my tail ten years and you levitate half
an inch
hey leave it it's not even good as a
levitate tell me would you I'd do it
even if you could levitate for half an
inch after ten years what in your point
you get a little bit of a following like
me like I'm a fast talker and so I get a
little bit of Apollo right yeah people
who talk normal they get no following
people who talk slow and deliberate yeah
that's the grown-ass dude that's the
Matt con that's the Joel Osteen um we're
red flags and hey guys tell me if I'm
tell me if I'm cocking it here John's
gonna be a little [ __ ] over here last
thing I wanted people in the comments
Chuck chucking around Canada but dude
there's guys that are like I meditate my
medications so powerful and he and he's
like he's like that I can put a fire
here for ten minutes
and then he puts his hand or hey what
are you doing there hey Angela welcome
back the coffee Zilla back by popular
demand dude listen I couldn't have
stopped you coming back on here if I
wanted to the people yeah Amis people
love it
guys know him you love him ameesha Patel
and he wanted me to mention this he just
want and actually this is actually big
deal you just want a Canadian
screenwriting award a round of applause
for him thank you thank you I was really
hoping I was really hoping that you
didn't you weren't gonna say that I told
you to I thought you were gonna be like
animation word and then I was gonna be
like oh you didn't have to say that yeah
I know it I did yeah yeah yeah I did I
was trying to set you up on that I was
trying to set you up on that but yeah
now that we're talking about it yeah no
I want a Canadian screenwriting award
for my work on Dino Dana it's on Amazon
Prime check it out great kid show I get
residual checks from it
take care of Baba you know what I'm
saying take care of Bubba hey and on
that note let's talk about a the new
name of what may become a regular thing
should the people request it so guys if
you love the episode throw a like on
this throw a comment tell tell a Miche
that you want more of him okay let's see
the hundred thousand guys watching I was
like texting you like hey say we need to
hit a hundred a hundred thousand that
sounds good hundred thousand views and
this will become the Laughing Baba's
podcast we'll make it a I don't know if
we can do weekly or bi-weekly but one of
those to either week I will see what we
can do we'll see how much content is a
limit sky's the limit
it really I was looking at our podcast
topics and I don't even think we're
gonna be able to cover it all today but
um yeah I'm thinking we just jump into
it I got any idea when I realized look
we were talking I didn't know this when
I we first chatted up you are like
seriously into the Buddhism the you know
you've taken a bunch of courses on it
you and this is my favorite thing ever
you created a a fiber logo which is
amazing mm-hmm drew it on the back of
someone else's background so we don't
legally have that background yet that
bat the blue part but whatever just put
it I mean it's not a big deal I'll give
you the blank put it up I'll put it up
you know yeah man yeah and I feel like
it qualifies you perfectly because I've
long wanted to talk about Indian gurus
but I've never really had any
qualifications and III feel like I'm
just stepping into a world I don't
understand and I don't know and so Baba
Miche is going to be our guide by the
way what does Baba mean I just thought
it was a funny name baba is a spiritual
teacher it's a it's body you can call
your dad that it's also means dad in
version that works yeah yeah well you
know Bob around us you know Baba Ramdass
know who's that he's a white guy
American dude and he just converted to
Hinduism at one point and he's a big
speaker dude
speaker across America he made it he he
brought the Hindu stuff over here
dude he's like man we're talking about
he lit it up he was with the guy who did
LSD and then he split off into strictly
meditation but you know the guy had the
famous guy who did LSD the turn on tune
in drop out guy they went to university
together and they went they did some
acid and then this guy said god is great
and God is great I was twenty believers
he was with Timothy Leary I think they
did a their part of that yeah manda
Baba's baby the white Baba's I love the
white Baba's white Baba's well now I'm
gonna have the laughing Baba's try to
get a laugh out of all this stuff so
let's just talk about I mean the fact
that you're immediately going to other
podcasters and trying to link you've set
up
I've set up a bitly link because I know
that people want to help
dude I mean the one thing that your fans
are so happy they care so much I know
they want to help me out you know when
we hit 50,000 that's when I got this I
said put the cowboy hat on a me she
deserve it god damn and we're the cowboy
hat and and and with pride and and so
for the people that I know they want to
help so I put up a little there's it's
bitly slash laughing Baba now and you
can go over there and if you have some
influencers that you want me to
collaborate with if you know someone in
the spiritual game you can go ahead now
you too can help out the laughing Baba
thank you guys so much
yeah dude I look I feel like I am a part
of a rocket ship right now the laughing
bah-bah I feel like I caught you right
on your come up you're gonna be huge
dude I guarantee you're gonna be huge
I'm glad I get to I'm glad I get a
witness that ok I'm glad I get to be a
part play a part what do you want to
jump into first man you've got a lot I'd
say very exciting what we're talking
about getting into the wu-tang with
podcasting and big news today for
podcasters Joe Rogan sold all of his
stuff to Spotify for a hundred million
but this is a news I think it's great
good cash it's a good cash but well this
is what I love about YouTube though you
know we could talk about the story
to it but I feel like we should talk
about a guy talking about the story who
is value Taemin I don't know if you guys
have seen this guy everyone in my
channel has seen value tainment you guys
know value Taemin okay hey value Taemin
I love him yeah I I love the review so
aggressive eh he's jacked dude he looks
like you could kill someone yeah anyway
he's explaining the numbers isn't he is
he military is he former military I feel
like he's I think he's a Dan Pina pupil
that's what I'm thinking I think he's
for this class hey I'm guessing he's a
day he said he's a Dan Pina like one of
those kids because men he's got the
aggression you know I'm saying you know
what I'm impressed by is sometimes I'll
watch a video and there's not a single
cut like he has the whole video in his
head before he starts recording like in
my videos if you don't watch every ten
seconds I'm like stumbling over my
remote and then I cut it so it makes me
sound all eloquent and stuff but this
guy he's looking at the camera he's like
he just monologues for 20 minutes and
I'm like dude will you blink or
something he's yeah when his eyes get
open - he's scary when he his eyes lock
on you that's when stuff starts to
happen listen you know that they didn't
take his interviews down they took a
bunch of Leonard reals interviews down
they he interviewed a lot of the same
people and some of his interviews
weren't taken down and I think it's the
piercing gaze
don't [ __ ] with him dude dude his
YouTube thumbnails it could be like me
my best friend eating ice cream and his
face is like he's cut he's like like it
always looks like he's about to hit
someone do the YouTube thumbnails okay
explain look there's I remember for when
I first saw him he made a video about a
mob boss do you see his mouth it's funny
though
when you look at that thumbnail I
thought at first he was the mob boss yes
he looked like a mob boss than the guy
who's the mob boss he's so aggressive
he's so like he wants to be that guy
right he's done he's a lion man he's a
lion and even when he's announcing this
Joe Rogan thing he's like hey guys come
here look at me right now Joe and he's
slamming these papers dude he's got to
be oh rogon hundred million dollars
Schurrle spotify
what does it mean I got the numbers
right here come here look at the numbers
I got the numbers right here hundred
million dollars to Spotify what does
that mean who's the agent YouTube
Google's they're losing money
Spotify went up five billion that means
someone else is losing money who did ago
she ate the deal Joe Rogan you come to
Texas I'll get your house don't even
worry about it
hey hey look at me I got the numbers
right here you come to Texas the
government's paying for your house and
that's it thirteen million dollars
switch the mortgage payment and you're
done I have the contacts Joe Rogan never
met him never met never met him don't
know him but if you come to if you come
to Texas I got us I got it dude the guy
he's intense but I did like what he said
which is this that he raised the value
of everybody else by I think I was like
that's true you saw the same thing
happen with like ninjas deal with mixer
ninja I don't know if you are followed
the gaming word at all ninja did this
huge gaming deal with mixer and the
right after that everyone got these huge
gaming deals and it was like I can't I
don't want to be quoted on this I think
ninja was basically the catalyst of a
lot of that I think he was the first one
but I feel like a coin podcasts are
about to get bought out because talent
war start I think it's a great time to
go to somebody else now everybody's
looking ok podcast or Spotify just did a
big move I want to do a move hey man I
got 50,000 on coffee Zilla I'm calling
my quinna you know what I'm saying we're
all [ __ ] greedy little dude see those
two girls on Barstow sports
they're just beefing in public sky and
report nor humans barstool sports
he hired he's like a guy like it's a
comedy channel but he goes on Tucker
Carlson a lot you know I'm saying maybe
a little on the right wing side sure
he's beefing with the AOC a little bit
like something I think you put out of
public tweet saying like if you guys
[ __ ] unionize you're all getting
fired and AOC was like hey that's
illegal I'm gonna do and then he went on
Tucker to be like [ __ ] you [ __ ]
business is America baby I'll fire all
these [ __ ] basically he's like he's
hard as [ __ ]
the two girls though they're like [ __ ]
you were leaving like his biggest
podcast I feel like we're at a new place
with with Twitter executives where they
don't care anymore dude like Elon Musk
is like like for 20 you know stocks
stocks - hi baby
like he's violating all these SEC rules
with Twitter yeah
what the [ __ ] Twitter and then what
about Twitter Benny the Donald Trump
[ __ ] did see that no you're not banning
they're like they're like we're gonna
fact-check you now and it's this is
gonna be the next craze in the next
couple of days obviously you know Trump
saying like go after that I think he
wants to sue them or something
he's like I'm suing Twitter okay real
quick let's touch on this time I know
we're we're already we're so far off the
laughing Baba trips but this is what
it's all about baby it is going after
the tree all right let's talk about
should platforms be just no censorship
let anything on that you want I mean
that's what he's basically saying is
that conservatives are being it's
prejudiced against conservatives we need
a basically free speech everywhere all
the time
London real same thing London real same
same thing value tainment I'm sure I
mean I haven't seen it but just just
based on how jacked and how aggressive I
know he's gonna have some [ __ ] don't
touch my videos youtube your Fox like my
interesting no he had the exact opposite
reaction he's like knowledge cool
[ __ ] Valley attainment did hey he's a
he's like Dori I got the back up I got
back up everything [ __ ] you like maybe
maybe he's just like chill he doesn't
care I don't understand what value tame
it makes money cuz in the video he goes
yeah I never took a dime from YouTube
and I'm like never gonna die I mean he's
he's in aggressive sales I mean it's
kind of like well I remember one of your
money one of the guys from the comments
section message me on Instagram and
there and I think there's a couple of
people there like like hey man so great
that you did that
copy Zilla thing I love that you guys
are calling out these con artists you
know great work so funny whatever and
then I go to his thing and it was like
crypto King ecommerce king course King
4xk treating King King King six months
six figures King did do everything I
love it
I do LA I love my audience but I feel
like some like 50% of them are some kind
of cocaine marketing team something King
actually I'm gonna say I'm gonna say 49
percent 51 percent of you guys are super
legit
super legit man they like to see
somebody get called out and then hey man
even the people that are doing the scams
they're nice people they're brainwash
men they're there they're actually
losing more dude I mean it's I know it's
hard to imagine the guy that you put a
couple of days ago who went to Africa
and he's just looking at a line of
people saying yeah if you buy or it was
a called future tech future trip tech
training oh my gosh yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh my god that's a guy's associate but
even when I'm watching his response I'm
just like oh he just he does have mental
illness right or no I don't know I'm not
to this excuse but I don't know I mean
the CEOs I don't believe have mental
illness I don't I think they knew what
they were doing yeah they're too smart
they kind of they knew what they were
doing the guy promoting all of it though
like he's jumping from thing to thing to
thing the thing he seems like he
believes that the guy who's saying he's
gonna save Africa
you mean he's like a crypto course King
Chrissie King yeah two for extinction of
those very seriously yeah I mean and
like the funny thing is is that after it
all went bust he's telling everybody in
the chatroom the victim chatroom hey
boys I got a new plan for you guys I got
a new opportunity because even I love
that be the augmented reality social
media network crypto koi it's just a
bunch of buzzwords these guys love
buzzwords
because video game cryptos hey the first
ever stem-cell backed crypto coin stem
cell back that's one of the things he
has he is very advanced technology with
the scamp's yeah I mean it's all about
layering some kind of it's called an ICO
scheme where like you pump up the coin
with all these promises of all this
technologies coming and then people buy
into it and you cash out okay I see what
they're doing they're all just yeah you
can't show it really is and it does get
hard to tell like where it's a scam wait
hold on
better you tell me whoa whoa sorry I was
looking at Patrick met David oh yeah oh
that's that's very Taemin yeah he runs a
multi-level marketing company or yes of
course these persons
real estate I thought he could be in
real estate though but you're saying you
say MLM for him okay cool okay that just
got so interesting I think I texted you
like this is the next Brian Rose
basically like this something's gonna
come up with him right I don't know if
it has to I feel like yeah yeah yeah
it's friends with the mob guys like I
mean you're asking I'm not ready I'm not
ready to do a full report on I I don't
know enough fact I just learned this
we're gonna we're gonna study
Patrick met David we're gonna come back
to him that's yes we're crazy
it is interesting now he is Persian but
he lives in Texas now and he's doing
these like Joe Rogan come to Texas the
government spending for your house I
don't know what was he talking about is
there some kind of tax loophole he's on
a murderer no Texas Lance is just cheap
did okay five dollars in California is
like fifty thousand dollars in Texas for
sure but I think he's talking about me
for your buck you get so much for your
buck and then you never know like
there's all these programs in America
too like we my parents or thing about
buying Florida real estate because you
know how even Donald Trump talks about
this thing when economy goes shitty
that's opportunity baby
so for years Florida
Las Vegas like off the strip they were
like you know ten twenty thousand
dollars for condo and then you just add
on other stuff whatever but then there
always are these weird government
schemes they were there were these
government's things where it's like if
you're from out of the state reading
another 10,000 but if you're in so maybe
Patrick by David's got some [ __ ] but he
is super shady seeming like with the mob
guys he likes that
yeah yeah you know I mean he likes that
I I feel bad because I feel like I'm
like throwing out accusations
hey if you can get him you can get him
but right but but he does seem like the
kind of guy who likes to gamble maybe
and who likes to play on the edge like
just being friends with the mob guy like
these mob guys are coming on his show
talking about how they killed a bunch of
like if I can kill people man huh I know
what I mean they've met like five
hundred people in their life they've
killed 250 that's a 50/50 dice roll
exactly you think telling is what does
he tell his wife he's like don't worry
Arnie I got a
coming over it's like dude this is weird
like I mean you could get yourself
caught up in some [ __ ] but maybe it's
fine I don't know he wants to be that
guy who can play on that level though so
he's [ __ ] you know yeah I think that
I think that's right I think a lot of
these guys at the Hyatt they just a lot
of the mentality is that money talks and
the way you get to the next level is
you're just making a certain amount of
money and that's the only way to get to
cuz that's like that was London reals
whole thing and I want to talk about
Lenin real because I've done too many
videos about him I don't want to make a
whole dedicated video let's just touch
on him real quick he's at Leicester City
stuff but one of the things he talks
about and I thought oh this is a
mentality I would never have he goes oh
yeah we have to have a war chest of a
certain size to be respected by these
platforms but but honestly I don't
understand because those are trillion
dollar platforms and you're talking
about raising a million dollars that is
like that's nothing they don't respect
you they start going crazy though like I
do think him Alex Jones it's mental
illness a little bit like he they're
getting these paranoid delusions in
their head of like there's someone
coming for us and we're gonna do it now
you could it's hard to tell who's lying
and who's telling the truth
if inside and then it's a gray area
because I know so much of the behind the
scenes stuff with London real that I've
never let out because so many people
have come to be behind the scenes of me
so many and I've it's so many of them
have been off the record nobody wants to
talk nobody everybody wants to talk but
nobody wants me to talk right that's
what they want they 105 they want an ear
to bend but if my audience knew right
now what I knew about London real
there'd be riots in the street baby how
many women how many women are like he
said on his chest and that he would
[ __ ] wipe it on like who knows what
kind of weird there's weird power
domination stuff going on there it's
just like Roger Ailes if you look at
Roger Ailes has come up and all the
documentaries about him are like but
he's like he brought hot girls to TV
this isn't it his innovation he's like
just [ __ ] supermodels take the front
of the desk out flash the light on the
legs baby all of them he just tries to
he's you know making a move he's like
what you don't [ __ ] me I own this place
madatha megyn kelly just that's why she
have to leave let me show you something
that's gonna show you everything you I
don't even have to say anything about
anything anyone's told me about Brian
Rose okay I'm gonna share my screen with
you right now and you're gonna see
everything you need to know about Brian
Rose I think the audience should be able
to see this too okay let's see if we can
make this happen
you're gonna love that you're gonna love
this you're not gonna laughing ba ba
baby you're not gonna you're not gonna
believe this
screen-sharing let's go okay hold on
watch this dude watch this watch this
okay today the most important person
that's ever come to London real and that
is do you see it the painting or officer
wherever it is it's a it's just tall as
him they're modern-day like Colonials
they're like sociopaths man look imagine
being that kid and look I'm nothing
wrong with bronzer but imagine living in
that shadow dude looking at that every
day it is that's like oh that is what
I'm telling you guys and some of y'all
are gonna tell me hey he didn't
Commission it painted somebody painted
it for him I don't care if you hate a
painting of yourself your size in your
own office come on man dude be cool just
do something cool in front of the
[ __ ] Eiffel Tower or fine you and
your what wish your wife and head dude
it's not even it's not like a picture
it's not anyone else in the thing of
like memorabilia or whatever it's like a
portrait of him like aspiration I like
yeah they have these right-wing
fantasies of themselves they're very
much like they want to be like that Iran
kind of character like I'm business I'm
industry I'm a [ __ ] man and I take it
balli Taemin has a painting up I think
himself - doesn't doesn't value Taemin
have a painting of him Martin Luther
King Milton Friedman he has Milton
Friedman Martin Luther King talking and
then he has a bunch of other I think
businessman like like
Emperor probably like right yeah yeah
that's his that's his on the Joe Rogan
one way I think it downloaded it is real
yeah he is he is the shabbiha Don he has
the shopping done this is why this guy's
hardest [ __ ] every Persian guy in over
this age has seen [ __ ] dude seemed
[ __ ] hardship they they what they
would he ran was going through when he
was a kid
this guy's fun some revolutionaries
stuff probably I wonder I mean I don't
know when he came over but most people I
know from Iran cuz that Shah over there
this guy in the background I don't he
could see him he's a third person it's
like Martin Martin Luther King well he's
got Joker on this side and he's got Hall
Incredible Hulk wow what a great studio
sexy a hold on oh I'm pulling it up
right now so I can share shared the
screen with everybody
I want everybody able to see what what I
see here oh my okay so this isn't the
same level but I want to tell you why I
think that I don't think it's the same
level alright but doing yourself is
redic this is what you're talking about
right this is what he's good he doesn't
know it's right there it's right there
this is great dude he wants to do my
gangster [ __ ] that's why he's got the
mob guys coming so now he's got one
racer over here he's got the shot of it
han lake in cool Einstein he's at
Kennedy who's that over there
that's Kennedy Milton Friedman Martin
Luther King Albert Einstein Lincoln
Richie
I don't know it's a racer I don't know
that guy that is a racecar driver that's
that's Aristotle no or left is marcus
aurelius you know this car is [ __ ]
hard stoic [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah Seneca I
think this is or maybe I don't know I'm
getting way outside my like no but I
don't know I kind of love the balls of
that to be like yeah I'm gonna paint
this six scene of all these great minds
thinking and great minds collaborating
the greatest minds of our era and why
not just throw myself in the dead center
of it all
dude it into him into Park orgy he's
just kicking it with him he's like
what's up bro
yeah all these business guys are here
but man I'm cool with you dude you're
like what you painted them all here too
like he's in the back with two bugling
he's too cool for his own
no I mean it's good well the only thing
about that is that feels somehow you
could interpret it as like it's
aspirationally who he thinks has
influenced him whereas I feel like that
Bryan Rose one it may be people other
people interpret it differently feels
like it's more like like I'm almost like
a god yeah by himself that chat dude he
[ __ ] works out hard eh that's a
that's piñas boy Ben yeah dude peanut
Valley Taemin has Patrick debate by
David he's got that pina tot feel but I
don't know who taught him pina though
has an interesting like work you're
gonna see a lot of sociopaths coming out
of pina I think because you got you
gotta London Brian Rose yeah no you know
Dan like Dan lock is also Dan pena de
long-eared and Pina yes yes on the Asian
side on the Asian side dude he teaches
them all and he gets that kind of
cutthroat make the money make the money
yeah me dangerous
yeah I have a testosterone level of 2500
its the snapping dude with Dave slamming
the table dude he's gonna break these
papers he's so Jackie reminds me of like
Kevin Hart did this bit about a guy gets
so Jack and then they just work at
[ __ ] AT&T and they're answering calls
why doesn't this guy need to be so
jacked
what's his Pro his program is like they
buy or they [ __ ] die hey come here
look at the numbers I drove two hours to
get here so who the [ __ ] gonna pay for
my guests [ __ ] you okay next up your
wife next room I'll [ __ ] you up like
he's aggressive but like not literally
that like you [ __ ] bi or I'm leap but
it's he's got that pressure he can he
can he can close people and I think he'd
be proud to say that I think that is the
point now I think if you're if you're a
CEO or you're in a sales role I think it
pays huge dividends to be physically fit
to have that intimidating if you're sort
of slovenly
it just goes along with the whole like
appearance of a Salesman is very well
kept very idealistic you know and the
way they're taught to operate is and
this is a whole type of guy and type of
business that really operates in the
sense of like we're at war we're gonna
go [ __ ] take this
market and I'm gonna dominate and I'm
gonna conquer I'm surprised he had I
mean here's Marcus Aurelius up there I'm
surprised even have a Genghis Khan
he seems like a guy that would put a
kangaskhan up there like just a
murderous dictator he's like [ __ ] yeah
baby I guess we go that far back though
you're allowed to put up Genghis Khan
now I think yeah that's so true that's
so true history is definitely what
written by the winners yeah he won and
he even took over China like I mean he's
he yeah no he's undeniable so I want to
hit two things on to get a poster okay
these things I want to hit online a real
before we go okay so he said he goes he
says the other day hey guys you know
first of all he's getting crushed in his
comments it's a little bit sad because
some of his comment sections are brutal
there's a guy named brain Rose who
comments on everything and he comes home
I'm and he's always like saying like I
love taking all y'all's money give me
more money give me more and he gets like
to the top of the comments the top of
the comment list until his comment gets
deleted and they think it's him oh yeah
cuz it's brain so they're liking him
they're like no no what they like the
fact that he's roasting the guy either
they think it's real and they like it or
they actually laugh because it's like
roasting him but uh never know but
here's the thing so he's been constantly
trying to do damage control now he's
realized it's a problem so one of the
big criticisms of him was that it wasn't
independent from London real so he
announced the other day hey guys the
digital freedom platform finally
independent we're launching it soon soon
soon and then he launches it and he goes
okay go to the digital freedom whatever
the domain is and uh and immediately I
click on it and I at first I think oh
this is an independent site but sneaky
Brian okay Brian is a sneaky fella sorry
we should call him brain rose brain rose
a sneaky fella
because a sub-domain of London real so
it's it's freedom dot Lenin real dot TV
independent oh my god this whole thing
was we're gonna make it independent
which is why I need all of your money
because I can't use my money because my
monies for London real this isn't
it from lender real no I gotta do
independent real then if he is called
out then he goes okay guys I'm doing it
all independent end up an independent
then it's whatever I got a fine I gotta
find the exact don't mean that this
guy's he is what he is just going in a
spiral right like he's going crazy he's
having like itches right I mean this is
thing with him Alex Jones David Icke do
remember I was doing stunt work on a
video game and this guy was reading a
fat David Icke book it was this fat okay
and he's telling me that like he's like
he's like three-quarters way through I'm
like oh what are you reading dude I'm
like kind of trendy joke about it he's
like no the lizards are here Miche and
you know I had to look I broke off my
engagement to work on this I told my
parents we're not talking anymore cuz I
got to work on this you got to get on
board um eh the aliens are here dude he
left his wife and his family he likes
tonight because he wrote he was he was
fully in on the David Icke lizard
conspiracy and he was like look man
these lizards are here I'm just gonna go
work on that okay you guys are just well
you want to go if have sex the lizards
are here how can you work how can you
think about yourself at a time like this
do you is like very upset I couldn't I
couldn't laugh at him I'm holding a task
that's hard to lie that's yeah yes you
guys wanna meet you
that's hurtful I've been dying I want to
talk to you about I want to bring
something you coming term because the
Gujarati even say it you're like oh god
Rotti Gujarati who trotty the Gujarati
police were after this guy and I my
tears good perked up I know it's like
okay I've got to bring this up to a
Miche have you heard this guy I don't
even know if I'm pronouncing his name
right least Theon Nanda Nityananda oh
you do it right off the bat okay there's
no the name I've heard the name
Nityananda okay but tell me I want to
hear it like a good guy this guru this
is the kind of guru that I've been
waiting to talk about for someone like
you
I have several clips several IDI none of
you are gonna believe a single one of
them exists the first one is a
levitation summit and this guy runs a
levitation summit and it's these
levitation folks
since I was a kid I'm like you know you
meditate for enlightenment and these
guys are like my uncle since I was kid
he's been doing these Hindu ceremonies
sorry I started but these ceremonies and
he was telling me for years that like
these guys would be like you're doing
you're doing weddings I'm levitating
[ __ ] that [ __ ] like they're dissing him
like he's like a wedding band guy you're
doing weddings bro I'm doing [ __ ]
levitation within 10 years and you
levitate half an inch hey leave it it's
not even good as a levitate tell me I
could do it even if you could levitate
for half an inch after 10 years why
didn't your point [ __ ] do there's
guys that are like I meditate my
medication so powerful and he and he's
like he's like that I can put a fire
here for 10 minutes
and then he puts his hands things like
what's these magic power gurus I'm not
gonna the Laughing Baba does not condone
any magic power
this life is magic the fact that we're
alive is magic that's here they're being
enlightened is its own reward this is
what the Buddha teaches but anyway tell
me I want to see this Nithyananda okay
okay okay so first of all yeah did you
know I'm telling you you're gonna be too
shocked okay okay okay
okay check this out this he called was
his style of levitation they did like
jumping like they're like undulating but
yeah sure whatever call it levitation
I'm not gonna you know whatever first of
all though I want you to look at
something just chair he's the chairs
dude I want a Kickstarter laughing Baba
needs this chair that's it dude right
sorry interrupt but like it is it's got
like like leaves in it it's got tomatoes
spinach but he's a chair or a subway
[ __ ] addict it's like some of the
subway ads were there like look we got
all the fresh vegetables look but then
he tells a journalist that he can make a
levitate and that's where I'll be friend
away not really one and invited a man
from the media
the still photographer of a Canada daily
water headgear and waited hey what are
you doing there you're [ __ ] okay what
are these two white blonde ladies doing
there go home oh my gosh you already
handled Karen your inner calls okay so
so that's clip one okay that's it just
one okay and I want you to notice
because the chairs change baby that's
the first thing I noticed I said this
guy's chair game is off I want to know
I'm saving the best chair for last okay
say I'm excited yeah so uh it's better I
want to know I just want to know where
did he get these chairs dude I swear
where's the store I can get these chairs
I don't this is a custom chairman this
is a Hindu there's a Hindu wedding
ceremony guy can get you these chairs if
there's I guarantee you there's someone
around there Hindi cuz Indian people
there's such psychos with their weddings
let me tell you a scam $100,000 per
wedding dude
my cousin got married I was in the
wedding divorce in six months hey second
wedding $80,000 no name no no way are
you serious so many people do this 100
and 100 K Canada but if they're American
they just end up spending a hundred K
American - it's [ __ ] up I don't know
what it is you just said it a hundred K
that's the number
dude the wedding industry it's all about
keep up with the Joneses and if you can
set it up there everyone they go there
go
there me and my wife we were like yeah
we're gonna do a cheap wedding spent 30
not 30 20 grand on the wedding ended up
and it's like do we don't have that kind
of money we got we got help from our
parents luckily I mean we're pretty
fortunate but that's where that's where
brown privilege kicks Brown that's a
hundred thousand all parents dude yeah I
mean that's insane I wonder if they have
financing like they have like special
financing for that that's nice alright
dude this guy's chair okay this one in
this one I want to set up this clip
instead of his clip so he says that he's
gonna stop the Sun and that he was he
woke up late I think so that he decided
just to stop the Sun so this is a
different guy
it is supposed to be six forty two seven
I told the Sun don't come out til I
finish the jar or no were there two
minutes and sundries late see the busy
sunrise time today see there's a Google
thing there's a website where the
sunrise time is supposed to be time an
actual time is recorded today will be 40
minutes late
wait wait applause applause just kicks
it what I've got a reshare this with you
guys look at this crowd here that's ty
did a Miche this is what you need baby
do are you watching joel osteen brother
you got Joe Losey right there he's great
I love him I you know I love him I know
I know have you seen have you seen the
snake healing guys there's some snake
healing guys in I think they're in Texas
or South Carolina they do like mumbling
and then they do like and now it's gonna
save you and the snake just bites ya
know it's a huge thing the snake anyone
but another one from India that was in
South Carolina I think that guy and dude
the son that the dad died and then the
son from it and the son would took over
the church and I think he like he might
be in the hospital right now or he went
off like three weeks ago cuz the dad was
a snake it was like a church snake
charmer Church guy that said God is so
great god is great god is great and it
won't it won't poison me but he would
but they do this in his family this
church they just take it like they just
get they constantly cream purchase you
gotta give it to him though they're not
getting some fake-ass snakes dude
respect on that dude respect on that hey
Dad they're flexing dude they're like
[ __ ] I'll take it dude he's begging
please don't do it you'll end up like
your dad and he's like dad I'm gonna be
like daddy what does he say what he got
out of the hospital like but I didn't
die though I think he said God tested me
and I I don't know about I don't know
about that there's another guy in India
he does himself right and then he bled
the people bless themselves they
literally like take this DVD go listen
but the work but the people in the crowd
they took the DVD he wasn't saying take
it home he they took the DVD physically
and they certainly there's a video I did
a video of that I'll send it to you yeah
we gotta get this we got to get the
clips I'm gonna click OK if you don't
have the clip
we could share screen on Jim dude we're
going to study yeah I like the reactions
dude look but okay did you notice the
chair though did you share sexy the
chair game is sexy he is getting sexy
yeah okay if that's the same guy first
he was like a little nerdy boy and in
the second one he this guy look it's a
bit not as big it's not as big it's
proportionate but its ornate look at me
dude and it's silver I like it I like to
insert a gold human silver he went sexy
lean he's in the middle you can see
growth in this Babaji you know what I
don't I actually don't like that one as
much because I don't like that it's not
huge I like the ones that are
disproportionate with his body where it
looks like he's a small child sitting at
this big Anik throne so this one's
almost not tacky like this one's
actually kind of sexy was the first one
it's like okay you're sitting on a
vegetable second one sexy like I could
get the second one in my house and like
you could you could date someone and
there's like a 70% chance that who are
like a normal girl like with a job could
be like I'll let you keep that you know
saying don't I totally agree it's like
you're his first chair no way that's oh
that's like that goes that marriage that
goes that you know we're done but here's
the thing I was playing you number two
second because number three is it next
up and you got understand it's not just
about the chair game listen to what he's
saying cuz he's about to introduce the
idea that none of you have heard of him
before which is called the veg brain
okay have you heard a brain it's the
brain of a vegetarian and there's also
vegetarian I it's it's kosher
in fact you're gonna love it you can
actually love this dude the meat eaters
like me I'm offended right now okay not
egg brains he flexes on the non-veg
brain check this out oh he's ripping and
dipping that's not appropriate Hinduism
but let's check it out I can't wait yeah
yeah
oh he rips and dips check it out he's
not the dog kept a Buddhist
first of all chair check out the chair
it's nuts
it's where does the chair end and where
does the world begin dude this is the
world's big this is like a magic chair
ooh game on point in the middle he's got
a leopard that's the best thing we get
all dude that's an amazing and I want to
believe it's probably not true but if I
want to believe every time this guy sits
down it's on a new better chair than
before if God is great anything is
possible not at all capable to
understand the higher intensity does not
need to be reduced spark can be nobility
non-witch brain knows only ups and downs
non-veg brains like me my brain only
knows ups and downs he's about to
challenge Einstein's theory of
relativity cannot win up continuously
only a person who knows continuous up is
possible he can grasp without reducing
the intensity continuity is possible
never a common brain understands
intensity and continuity infinity and
continually some of the major science
what's that Brown science is kind of
like bro science but when you relate it
to a religion that's what I call it
that's just my own invention I call it
brown science but I like his sigh I like
that I like when religious people start
talking science it's my favorite dude
this is incredible yeah it's got titties
I'm debunking e equal to not MC square
cannot be what is matter matter is
continuity energies intensity what is
matter anything continue what do you
call us energy does it need a sign
language expert because he is speaking
through his hands the whole time dude
yeah good speaker man very tight to
Cherokees chair game I point the pacing
on
I realized I realize people who really
get a following you get a little bit of
a following like me like I'm a fast
talker and so I get a little bit of a
following right yeah people who talk
normal he had no following people who
talk slow and deliberate yes get the
wheel following that's the grown-ass
[ __ ] dude that's the madcon essential
Osteen that's the Matt con that's the
Joel Osteen we're gonna get today
because I have one more chair for you I
love that we're both like you show me
the brown guys I'm gonna show you the
white guys this is perfect perfectly
it's great okay and I'm not gonna like
this is my favorite chair yet they do
keep getting better like I know the
second was smaller but he was a tighter
chair but the third one was like yeah I
couldn't even have shown you the fourth
chair because you're a veg brain even
your veg brain was not ready in this one
the title of it is I will remove non
vegetarian lifestyle from Earth and I
will make human beings vegan check in
five hours
Suns gonna be 40 minutes late it is okay
get ready look at this chair first of
all look at this Titus it's gonna zoom
out in a bit and we'll pause then but
that's the start of the chair that's
like a third of the chair I like to look
- I like his beard I like this look he's
going back to the trade the mint the
second one and the last one this guy
yeah he's getting it he's getting he's
getting it in - you know I'm saying dude
just wait just wait this is I got a lot
free we became a third-rate beings
really sorry to flip please don't be
hurt but I'm what I'm saying
that's a green-screen that's gotta be
I'll of this forever dude look at that
chair baby his feet couldn't touch the
ground if he tried he's barely holding
he's straddling that thing as best
decision I think he he could barely
handle it that is a joke that is though
it's at the edge of his capacity to
handle spiritual warrior it's twice as
tall as him look at this is twice as
tall as him to Lyons Oh Mike Stan can
barely reach him if you look at that it
is exuded a double extender he has a
double extender mic stand yeah normally
you don't need this double extender
right to go to him but like for this
chair you can't have the stand blocking
the chair you need the double extension
on that Mike did he yelled at someone
he's in [ __ ] figure it out you had a
double extender chair like that's so
thing I ever need only am I do have to
admit that like in Western culture we
don't put on like I don't want to say
airs because that implies that like III
don't know there's like a showmanship to
this that I feel like Westerners don't
really adopt but I would love a chair
like that I wish it was socially
acceptable for people to come in I have
a painting that size on one wall of
myself yeah and then I have a chair that
big that I'm not even I'm not even in it
really at all and I'm just like this hey
man I I know some guys over here that
can help you get there
and it is amazing dude sorry that's sexy
dude that is hot the religion game is
tight all over I mean Hindu the thing
with India right is that Hinduism is
like an open source religion you can
just come in you can be like oh I'm the
reincarnation of that guy they let Pete
do you can come in have you got the
numbers you're in the game baby that's
it so it's about numbers it's about a
following and once you have the
following you're in once you got the
following you kind of get command this
respect and like nobody questions
spiritual people over there in
America there's a strong atheist
movements that really fight back against
that the Indian atheist movements man
they have such a hard time getting off
the ground because at the same time as
they're going there's guys coming from
America that are like hey you gotta get
you gotta like [ __ ] beat up a gay guy
or something like there's have you ever
seen that eat that poo poo have you seen
that video
no you're seen the video so there are
preachers that go from the south they go
to Africa they go to India to do
missions I mean Joel Osteen does too but
I love Joel Osteen but they'll go and
they'll be like if you want to come up
in your church game you got to start
saying some homophobic [ __ ] so this guy
in Nigeria he starts doing like he
starts doing pastor like in his church
he started teaching like this guy is
American and he is eating the poopoo
the Americans eat the poopoo and it was
like a slice Fred about gay people that
gay people do this and in America they
allow this well we are not going to do
it I'll send you the video is a classic
Christian preacher I think he got AIDS
in the end and I didn't maybe I know and
we can't say that aids is not saying
that but terrible amazed careful now
careful now beeping laughing Baba's very
PG been very peaceful clean I wanna you
know we're respectful here look I'll
talk about anything I don't care I'm
saying you gotta talk about it these
guys are very damaging to India I mean I
don't know what this guy is doing but
there's a lot of them and they're
vicious man they eat people and and and
the game really is if you can come to
America if you got a couple of blonde
girls in the audience this guys doing
good that's how you know did you gotta
get that American money i Indian money
thing good yeah the the power corrupts
they have a lot of power here let's see
if we can see that Norma means they're
lower level being snow yes partner you
look at that pause or is he pausing he's
paused he's pause right now mother abuse
me
second the mic is cutting out the mic is
cutting out no like not cutting out like
the mic is stopping recording because
you're not saying a lute I will remove
right now knowledge didn't life stay
from Planet Earth let's do the Whitey's
are right here they're right here can
you see my mouse I can't see your mouse
places dude I don't know from this angle
I'm just seeing like it a turd I'm
seeing like 20 no 10 white girls it's
all girls suit and from this angle kind
of cute one asian girl in the front what
are we looking at we got is anyone black
it's hard to tell but there are
straight-up just like some American
white girls or maybe they're European I
don't know look on the right side we
have a couple of white guys there too
there are a lot of white people yes ah
yes hey lights it's they like to Bob us
do you like the Baba's and they like bug
ones okay so check this out I have a
twist for you I have a twist cuz
remember at the beginning of this I said
the gujarat police did I said I write
Gujarat police got involved now wait
just a second
not knit yonder wait Nithyananda I got I
get confused on the nananana anyway yeah
unda knit as I will call him because I
can't possibly put it easy yeah you comb
it yeah nit nit he had a rape accusation
against them dun dun da these guys are
[ __ ] they're Shady well it's just
they have too much power so much power
because I feel like when you are just
uncool I don't know so the thing is is
he got accused of that of course his
followers say it was all a hit job but
everyone else they won't yeah yeah they
won't turn him well no because in the
20th of November of last year like just
a couple months ago he fled the country
he fled the country and
but an island and created his own
country now and god is great in god is
great cause I worked Kailasa is the name
of the thing no I'm just saying it like
he looks like a Hindu warrior he looks
like like just to the whole get like his
outfit he's got these bars over there
like he is
these guys are religious leaders men but
they are ready to fight let me know show
you saw Oh show right over here he's a
calm children long pauses did you see
his documentary well well country yeah
incredible right so great documentary I
mean this guy though when they did all
they when they look into the now I mean
did his top woman was poisoning the town
he the the American officials when they
started looking into it they're like oh
you already [ __ ] up some people in
India ran away from there like he I
don't think he was allowed to go back to
India
yeah he anyway sort of the city here
yeah running away and starting a city
that's the move because you run away you
I think they just did do a money grab
and goodbye I don't think and I think
the end like India is probably happy you
know they're like okay well lease is off
our hands where is the city it's near
Ecuador I think Oh a private island near
Trinidad and Tobago or Ecuador smart oh
they call it a micronation
oh so he's not quite at the nation level
but he says I'm bad and he runs this
town who's there though anyone is it
maybe his own I wonder like you did for
all the risk oh oh yeah oh yeah you got
some footage from micro from it I was
trying to find so that's like I feel
like I'm disappointing you a little bit
clips for literally everything else but
chairs over there man they got to be
insane uh yeah I feel like I saw one
thing and let me see if I can find it so
this guy did a news piece but he's
talking in a language I don't understand
I don't know if it's Hindi or or or do
but
let me share safely I'll tell you modern
cinema would in order would get a bigger
vision ah yeah
what is this tamil I don't speak this
Indian he might be South Indian actually
he looks like he's something but that's
where the island is all the way over
there the island is right here yep and
then they have a few pictures of like
him over there I guess see that Beach
let's see the beat dad that's nice sexy
sure he took the sleek and sexy one hey
you know what the big one let's be real
the big one couldn't fit on it no they
had him on the run that's the thing that
he's mad about there he's like give me
my chair he's calling some states in the
chairman yeah he's got a microphone I
mean he's got everything that is the
story of NIT and yeah I still can't say
his name but I love that story I was
beautiful that story every week I want
bigger chairs I wanna I want a green
screen where I have that chair I'm gonna
be something I'm gonna create it don't
done you gotta create it you and I'm
gonna say something man like you've
opened a Pandora's box that you don't
even know this is just the start this is
a good it's a good laughing Baba day one
that's nothing dude I got a guy that'll
knock your socks off dude like like
there's a guy that he is rock and roll
in India - he's in India - and he he's
always getting in and out of jail
connected with crimes [ __ ] a little bit
there it's it's that's what I need
that's why you're laughing bah-bah
you're laughing Baba I'm laughing Robert
that's how we got to do laughing bah bah
that's it I guess I do have these clips
over here I mean I don't know if I
wasn't planning on it but we can try it
let me uh if you have a time code I can
splice it in later the mo true well I
was gonna show you this Joel Osteen clip
where it's basically okay so it came out
after covet okay yeah came out dr.
Colbert he
is his church nobody's going in by the
way if you want to tell everyone I'm a
huge Joel Osteen fan like this I know is
gonna come across like I'm making fun
now making fun man the inspiration that
you're gonna get from this guy my
attitude is he deserves it god damn it
I love these [ __ ] white Baba's they
went and learned from those guys in
India I don't know how I mean this guy
didn't put the other white Baba's that
I'm into yeah they all learned from
India they're so sweet they're so nice
they're friends with all those osho and
all those guys but I can't see if
they're being doing like gangster [ __ ]
or anything corrupt Joel Osteen I love
my white friends they get mad at me
they're like why you listen to this this
thing how come you're not a Athey come
on man don't listen to that stutter you
go to church dude what's that there's a
lot of hate on religion here but I'm a
Hindu areas there let's let's clear the
air about the Baba's and religion okay
because I I come from a religious
tradition of Christianity you come from
a religious tradition as well right
where Hinduism are you still a
practicing Hindu
I mean I'm practicing what I'm getting
into is like Tibetan and Buddhist
meditation to bed a little bit for
solidarity because of what they're going
through right now they got kicked out
there and in here right now they're
getting screwed yeah the Chinese
government just took it and they're in
India right now actually as we speak
there's a thousand Chinese troops on the
Indian side and they're just saying what
are you gonna do what were you telling
me about like something you told me
something crazy about they like own the
Dalai Lama now in China now oh so in
China what they did is they don't want
the Dalai Lama to name his successor
because like China is a colonial power
is a very calm and patient long game
kind of strategy
they walked into Tibet like they did
they do everything so legally - they
went into bed and they were like we're
annexing half the other half whatever
they did attack them like they just beat
the ship there's footage of them beating
people they're like you know allowed to
meditate at the Dalai Lama there and
they're not allowed to fight back
because they practice loving-kindness
meditation so basically they're getting
beat up they're basically like no
meditation dude there's people that are
like there's a guy standing there with
the steak is like hey no meditation no
meditation oh so like someone's like how
have you stopped
you close your eyes are like wacky
you're very loud dude they're metaphysic
like it's like very loud I think they're
not but also know they're it's like
Chinese torture man it's like this
region cancer I know the Muslims in
China right now they're being sent to
re-education so you're gonna go to
school and not be Muslim anymore you're
not okay yeah I'm not okay obviously but
but let's not you know your Tibet with
the takeover of Tibet I did just get my
degree in Buddhism so we talked about
this actually from Harvard X we're gonna
come back to the Harvard X things like
I'm dying to talk about that but yeah
yeah but but but yeah the Dalai Lama
what he's so sweet when I was younger I
was like I really love Buddhism when I
heard the story I was like hey man can
you [ __ ] levitate and tell these
[ __ ] to get out then you know in my
head I'm like not understanding but but
really that he went to India because
they believe in loving kind of state
they're not allowed to fight back Gandhi
did the same thing Martin Luther King
did the same thing it's very effective
actually it's long game it's the long
game because immediately you lose but
you win the hearts and minds of everyone
watching because nobody likes seeing the
oppression of another class and my point
my point in bringing up both of our
interest in spiritual things is because
we're gonna make fun of a lot of gurus a
lot of spiritual gurus our point isn't
that if you believe in something or
don't that you're dumb or whatever our
point is is that there clearly everyone
could agree that with this stuff a lot
of charlatans get away with a lot of
stuff and they need to be caught up you
know what they need to be caught up
because this is like an area where
people are more vulnerable than anywhere
else because all of a sudden you inject
you know like just believe in there and
people go bananas our brain goes haywire
and we lose all our money and we believe
some wild stuff so where could you
district so we're not we're not I just
wanted to say as the first episode of
the laughing Baba's you can watch this
you're not gonna get offended if you're
someone a belief or not a belief but
guys just stay here for the laughs the
gasps and understand we're going at this
with a light heart thank you that's
great man thanks for that that was me
wanted to put it in there because we
we're gonna be sick after every sacred
cows baby yes we gotta go after them and
we have to do it with loving-kindness
and this is this is the Buddhists this
is the Buddhist way it's beautiful the
loving-kindness meditation it's the
correct way it's like we're it can't
come from a place of hate can't come
from like I hate you this is why I
genuinely do love Joel Osteen I think
it's a beautiful teaching yeah but
here's what it fascinates me about Joel
Osteen because I didn't watch him fur
till I was probably 22 I've never I've
never seen him I never heard of him even
though he's closer to me he's he's at
Lakewood which is in Houston um from in
like I'm in Texas San Antonio so I'll
just spoil it real quick I'm so close
okay I'm so blessed baby I'm so blessed
I'd never heard of him and then all of a
sudden I hear about this guy that's like
renting out sports centers or whatever
it sounds like god this guy's an idiot
whatever and so I watch one of his
things and here's one thing that I took
away I've never seen somebody who's
smile is on permanent the smile is nuts
dude it is it is a chair it is a
gigantic new Teufel chair if we could
make it a because no matter what he says
like I feel like he could say any words
and you'd be like yeah this guy is
likable but you've got a what but you've
gotta wonder dog is coming on but you
got a wonder though about I mean isn't
there a bunch of things against these
megachurch people about they take too
many money that you don't need that much
money you know you're Joel Osteen look
he's big on the sports cars that's
because God wants him to be abundant he
the Lord wants us to be abundant well
you didn't tell me you had a Joel Osteen
voice that's amazing he has a message of
love dude I love his he has one preacher
sermon where he's talking about like
he's talking about how
I love he said they said Joe you can't
love the Hindus do you love the he said
I love the Hindus Joe he goes I love the
Hindus I love the Buddhists
I love the Muslim and did the crowd was
like holy [ __ ]
what like what dude he brings the heat
on him in Texas he said I love the
Muslim - you know what he and and that T
you know what that story was he abusive
a story about how so so all these other
preachers they hate on him hey hey hey
he got he's got haters you know God
knows he got haters yeah God sends
haters to let you know you're on the
right track haters to let you know dude
that's there Joel is gonna text you dude
he's gonna be your next influencer you
go on because he didn't be like yo yeah
thank you a Miche he's having a hard
time the churches that no one's coming
to church I'm watching it he's barely
doing the joke at the beginning he just
a joke it's just silent the last one I
watched he does the joke is like hey
y'all thanks for tuning in on YouTube no
one could come in but I'm gonna do my
best to bring the energy for you guys
okay well let's start and then he goes
he's like he's like he's like I stopped
doing the jokes but they keep telling me
in the comments that they want the jokes
to come back alright y'all well I got
this one free here and he does it and
then like there's no laugh but he's just
so like he's working for God baby he's
working to bring inspiration I just
seems so genuine to me and it's so
positive it's positive yeah I I don't
know though I mean I just I get listen
here's the thing here's the thing I get
suspicious and when religion gets too
big I feel like for the same reasons
with the Guru why there was like like
the like the rape stuff and like I don't
think that's coincidence
that someone who sits on a chair that
big is having issues you know yeah your
head I think it goes to another place I
don't think people actually I believe
the same thing about Fame
I think Fame makes people go crazy when
you get too much attention too much
power to much anything it's not good for
you you weren't equipped you know we
were yeah we were so we were some little
tribe you know you had 40 friends total
you know at your best you had 40
followers now 40 followers your loser
dude just rips you out dude it's too
much so when I see something like
there's no fair enough it's hard to tell
when numbers get this big you are
looking at sociopath area I mean and
it's sad because it's not just seen in
this stuff even look at Hollywood you
look at someone like Cosby you look at
someone like in Canada this guy Jian
Ghomeshi told everyone he was a feminist
and he's obviously just beating the [ __ ]
out of girls and like you you almost
there was a minute there where I was
like can you make it today without being
a [ __ ] sociopath like do I have to
hurt I gotta step on someone's neck just
to make 80,000 or something like it it
is easy to lose faith yeah but Joel
Osteen ooh look okay yeah there he is
right okay but look at how big that
stage it's too big it's too big he's got
a globe the size of almost the globe
he's got the stairway to heaven over
there like literally you love the Hindu
with the chair but you can't respect the
creature no that's not what I'm just
saying I wasn't surprised when the chair
guy had a problem and when I see Joel
Olsteen
with the problem I'm not gonna be
surprised I'm not saying I I don't know
I really don't know meant that much
about him other than he's got a problem
in LA like someone really tried to make
like people are trying to get after him
and like I'm such a Joel Osteen defender
I know I do I love Jesus more than the
liberal I'll tell you that right now
Jesus more than the liberal do you know
that I was that I was that I've always
been into this guy but I've always been
into Jesus too since I was a kid because
Hindus it is open source in that sense
to where we're just like you know we'll
check them out that's cool baby that's
cool I like your kind of the buffet man
you got this this this you got this you
like a little bit of Tibet I like it
listen life is in it for a Hindu I guess
you know then I think people are gonna
like just from our conversation so our
people are gonna love this podcast hey
you think so you think cause of the Joel
Osteen defense I don't know people don't
like Joel but you know what the Laughing
bomber
missions listen the Baba's are not for
popular appeal babe
wherfore is the real deal
yeah he's poetic he has beautiful
inspirational stories he's equivalent of
like of like Chicken Soup for the Soul
dude like it's it's it's fluffy but he
takes a Christian teaching and makes it
accessible makes it very secondly I want
to say secular a little bit because he
actually has other preachers he got
haters did he's got haters because he
was on Piers Morgan right and and Piers
Morgan said hey say you hate gay people
cuz it's in the Bible say you hate them
and and Joe Losey said hey I don't hate
it the but he's like I don't hate them
they're a child of the Most High God how
can I hate them and then and then and
then piers is like you know the Bible
says it's a sin to to be gay and enjoy
loosing a class a cure he said he said
that's now that's true piers but the
Bible also said it's it's a sin to get
angry and God knows I get angry
sometimes I'll tell you I'll get angry
he did the thing is he doesn't even get
angry he gets this angry and he's like
well I'm sinning and then the gays are
sinning and that's fine piers we can't
judge them and then and then he's other
preachers come to diss him dude they
come to [ __ ] protest against him cuz
they're like why didn't you [ __ ] say
gay people are wrong or whatever there
is a lot of it's funny how much
gatekeeping there is in various you know
religions you doing your own thing and I
think part of its the success I mean
Joel Osteen's obviously huge and maybe
that's part of it you know all right I
should be mistrustful of him a little
more I just haven't seen anything like
like there's pseudoscience I mean I was
I have a clip here right now where he's
like he's like when Jesus he sang about
how Jesus when he was on the cross he
was whipped 39 times there are 39 types
of ailments in the medical journal I
call that Brown science when you take
your religion just go bing bang we
invented it dude Hindus are taking
credit for Santa Claus or example of
that but he did it's it's positive it is
sure I'll give it to you like maybe I'm
being naive
maybe he no but you know maybe one of
them too is I've noticed that I think in
America we have a real thing about
mistrusting like the dominant cultural
thing yes and I think you know I mean if
you had to define it in America
it was white male Christian yes yeah and
that became the thing and so then it's
like okay we're just gonna hate I think
as a to may be an unfair degree baby
we're giving a hard time it's and I say
and I say that jokingly obviously you
know the privilege of it but people
would there's a lot of diversity stuff
and people will be like how can they put
a white man in there how come a white
man is on that show and I'm like you
know it's been his dream since he was
five what are you gonna do you gonna eat
him to kill himself like he's he's here
and he's alive and he's just doing just
living his life so like I get it weed
there has to be you know certain things
to equalise stuff but I don't think
hating people is the way to go I think
it's all about loving kindness and even
if we're that's why on the show even if
we're roasting someone I love it it's
gonna be like hey man not softball and
that doesn't mean softball because yeah
the teaching they like the Buddhists and
that kind of philosophy is to treat
things with loving kindness but you need
the lemon kindness because you're gonna
deal with everything head-on we're not
gonna avoid anything so we're gonna go
ahead on with love it's a it's a very
good powerful power for you right there
hey hey hey that sounds like a guy who
got his Buddhist degree from Harvard
let's talk about Harvard X for a second
we just got real heavy let's take it
back a little soft baby let's get it
back to the stop boss okay after saying
we're gonna deal with everything head-on
you just got a degree in Buddhism from
Harvard now when you first said this I
think you just told me Harvard and
you're like Harvard yes
[Laughter]
so tell people what our vertex is did I
love it Harvard X I love dropping the X
on that years ago I was on this kids TV
show they applied for an Emmy a Daytime
Emmy the real one you guys and a fly for
the Daytime Emmy I was like as a
comedian it's good that it's enough that
they applied I just started telling
people didn't even get the nomination
mm-hmm 2018 any nomination applicant
that's [ __ ] hilarious
that's amazing I like to put a star and
then at the broad I put applicant with
Harvard you can put star put X hey it's
certified I'm making my inroads with its
associated with Harvard that's it that's
it I say it man
dude you're making your inroads with the
bubble what's the game here dude you're
gonna roast these guys and then you're
gonna start your own thing you know
that's actually what they all do is all
these guys over an NG and they all say
like all the people before me they were
full of it and then they go start their
own thing um you know what they do they
pick a lane um you definitely look this
is the come up all over the world you
gotta have beefs and this is another
thing about Joel Osteen no beefs not
coming hating people but yeah definitely
in India they're beefing with like
cannibals like because you really only
could never one guru huh you can have
one guru in India or if you're going out
and paying money I want the [ __ ]
money
bring your $5 here but even Joel Osteen
he's one of my favorite Joel Osteen
Suri's he's talking about how there was
a preacher talking [ __ ] about him and
he's a great duelist he's beautiful
straight it's called having a wide
circle of love a lot of Joel isn't so
good so he's talking about how these
these creatures hey ya haters they're
talking [ __ ] about him they're mad at
him already protest him Hurricane
Katrina hit and they got a list of
churches that need help they need money
these guys are on the list he said he
said you know what I'm not sending them
that money I don't not gonna send it to
him they were they were they were hating
on me they're being real nasty to me and
then he said but I thought about it and
I prayed on it and God said give him the
money Joel it's the right thing and
here's the here's a he said he said they
drew a circle to keep me out
I drew a bigger circle and I pulled him
in we are friends now
we are doing each other's church I'm so
glad that I reached out to him and we
were able to solve whatever issues dude
this guy is basically like [ __ ] Joel
Osteen he's a fun he's gay [ __ ] him come
on loving kindness I drew a wider circle
bring them in
no here's the thing have you heard of
Matt Khan I'm certified in that Khan -
oh my gosh you've got certificates out
the yang yes I saw you sitting me
something called a galactic message I
want you guys to understand I love a
Miche we may not agree on Matt Khan I
haven't watched Matt Khan he'll come up
more as we go along I I have no doubt
okay so you sent me something called a
Galactica message by Matt Khan he's my
new favorite guy really
he's your is he doing over Joel Osteen
he's taking over his class very tight
whoa his class is a giant
loving-kindness meditation this is a
form of Tibetan Buddhism where you used
loving-kindness as a tool to heal
yourself emotionally it's very effective
I think the science is there I know that
sounds crazy but I'm talking about UC
Berkeley they all got into meditation
Jon kabat-zinn got into this meditation
- they're all like Westerners I'm one
with the white Baba's the white guru
Jesus right they're all a bunch of white
guys Harvard lawyers and they all like
Baba Ram Dass was probably the first one
you got Eckhart Tolle now but they're
all teaching this freaking Jack Dorsey's
like going on little summits little
meditation summit they're all in - yeah
all the silicon galletitas big money in
this laughing Baba is gonna we need to
get that speaking engagement it's gonna
be fifty thousand dollars that's it
that's it Oh fly-in fly-out fifty
thousand Jack Dorsey's here fifty
[ __ ] thousand that's right baby
all right so go do this last message
okay now do you want to play it or do
want me to just tell you well it's an
hour long okay here's the thing play the
first play the first like minute of it I
think it'll work and then I'll stop you
okay all right
we can cut it out if we need to yeah for
those of you that are new
I've already got a stop when he's not
talking he just looks like a cop right
like he just looks like a cop that would
beat the [ __ ] out of you why is there so
much breath if you everything for those
of you that are new what is it man
you're getting a little ESM are with
this guy you're getting for free okay
okay okay we're gonna go back in I just
had to take a quick look I just want to
tell everyone to that it is hard I'm not
just recommending this guy this is the
kind of guy that if I just send him
willy-nilly people are like hey are you
okay
you lonely dude what are you watching
like what the [ __ ] is this guy what does
he mean I get it it's very high-level
stuff it's basically a living loving
kindness if you think about it he's not
he kind of has the same belief as the
Dalai Lama but that's a stretch but
let's let's hear a little more let's
hear a little bit more when we gather
together
I am intuitively guided to share with
you insights to assist in your souls
journey whether that is to create deeper
moments of healing to transform aspects
of your life and to higher vibrations of
light or to assist you into awakening to
your true nature deeper and more
palpably than ever before I feel like
the static of the room is louder than it
is a lot it doesn't come together
I'm intuitively motivated and guided to
say the words but as I speak creates a
transmission of presence of an energy or
many celestial beings and masters
a cyst on my behalf that wasn't the end
of a sentence hold on watch this watch
this is amazing this is amazing
pause game no it's it's not a period
it's a comma listen to this karma hold
on watch this watch this
hold on
I skip five seconds back it wasn't even
the end hold on I listen to five seconds
and masters listen that's not the end of
the sentence I'm getting a full sentence
in that system I am ii have celestial
beings see that i don't believe in a
system my bad it's a lie I know it's a
lot okay so that does get okay I don't
believe in that I guess he's like Joe
Losey nuts instead like I technically
you know like we even Joel Osteen's like
he was like he was talking about Jesus
was whipped 39 times that's the 39 the
Medical Journal says there's 39 ailments
that affect us every year like you know
I don't believe in that science of it
but Matt Khan is a loving-kindness
meditation he's got a great philosophy
of life it is a little bit ASMR voice I
I get it he you know but but it is and
here's here's why I think he took the
spot from Joel Osteen for me this is why
this guy's on another level I wanted to
play the just that much it's fine but
yeah because joy okay look I'm a cop I
just stand up I'm watching Joel Osteen
I'm like this guy does a joke off the
top he's got funny stories ty I love it
respected he's going 22 minutes he's got
a teleprompter very professional
whatever right madcon no script
hey no teleprompter transmission from
the most high that's it he doesn't have
notes ever he transmits I don't think he
transmitted I think he thinks of his
entire speech as he takes an hour to
speak 30 words I mean if I had that long
to speak I think I could come up with
something too
I understand at 1.5 speed if we're
talking but do do two hours this guy's
read before two and there it's not fluff
he's got good stories like he there's
another one where he's basically doing
he does a lot of Portlandia trips where
all these like
kind of sad like white Portland he's in
Portland I think so all these like
depressed you know like - like sad and
yeah they're like oh like Western modern
right little black little yeah and he'll
totally just [ __ ] call him bunch of
[ __ ] like he's just like that's why you
guys are too weak to stand up to your
spouse and like you know just know he
doesn't say that he does great stories
he'll destroy but like it's called like
he does stories but they have jokes man
he has jokes here's what I want to know
so this guy's game how do you become a
Matt con like what is I'm so interested
in the origins no but I mean I mean like
the origins of these people who grow up
to be gurus like I would like I'm
wondering am I witnessing sort of the
transformation of a Miche into Bob Amish
right is that what's going on and if so
my mind is blown right now we're doing
it we doing I'm doing it you have to
start talking a lot store you're right I
do and a lot breath here a lot breathy
er lower - actually this guy doesn't
have a very low voice but he's got a
gravelly kind of breathy voice yeah I
talk fast a stand-up comedy so I was
doing stand-up here at a club and the
owner was like hey you're doing 20
minutes of material in five minutes slow
the [ __ ] down he's been telling people
me talking for years so you talk fast
man you're just running through material
calm down
so even in Stanhope it's like the thing
is if you're getting the full story done
hey I don't know if we're allowed to
talk about comics on this podcast but
I'd love to real quick okay I want to
know what you thought of this is such a
left-hand turn will return to Matt con
okay a left turn right turn whatever you
wanna call it I saw Chris Delia's new
special on them okay okay and I'm gonna
do this half hour now whatever you call
it I'm gonna say trash
oh it wasn't good I didn't think did you
see it
okay well now if I love this part I
think it's parties do hot cast hilarious
podcast hilarious he's stand-up was like
his podcast though where he took like
one riff about like oh gosh something
about a dolphin or so I'm gonna get this
wrong but it was some stupid thing any
riffs on here ifs on a single topic for
like 15 minutes rather than like hitting
a joke like you do in a special where
you'd like doctor joke and instead he's
like riff riff riff and you made me
think about it cuz you're talking about
like burning through material I felt
like instead of going through 20 minutes
of material in five minutes he went
through five minutes of material in 30
minutes yeah see at that point he's
doing him at con he's gone if you watch
him you're basically watching a stand-up
comic going really slow and Baba Ramdass
was like that jack Kornfield is like
that a little a lot of these meditation
[ __ ] they're doing jokes dude yeah
every joke well the thing is is when you
get to a certain level everybody wants
to be something else so when you're aid
an actor all of a sudden you want to be
a political figure right all the actors
think they're political guides to
everybody else
right it's true it's true when you
become a cop when you be get the highest
level comics like like Chris D'Elia he
was like high up there he starts doing
all this fitness thing it's like you're
not a fitness guy are you taking
yourself so seriously people yeah people
here are like we want very good we're
very much like stick to your thing man
you [ __ ] bring the heat on you I mean
I love America like that it's art is a
business here and it's like you [ __ ]
made something you do that thing forever
forever and also like stand-up is very
strict here you look at like and I like
that man I like that it's [ __ ] joke
joke joke I don't like this [ __ ] slow
a stand-up but in other countries they
get away with these like talking like
they do um even in America as you know
they do like storytelling show so they
like how many comics are just doing a
storytelling show and it's like well you
just polish and make a stand
because good stand-up is a story to like
you know what it is is people have
realized that the bar for entertainment
is actually low like some people they
just want a night out and they don't
care what it is like there's there's two
divergent ideas of art some people think
you don't come out of the cave until
you've created the greatest thing ever
you're you're Michelangelo or whatever
and then or you're David and you come
out and you're presented to the world
some people they're like you mass
produce some content baby people's don't
want greatness they want quantity they
want it shoved down their throat they're
bored to tears and they want more a
media America is like they take it to
another level man even the office in
England six episodes of season that's
right that's right that's it
it's a modest little thing they did more
than that in the second season I think I
think the second season of the American
office was like 25 episodes it just was
like 20 foot another time but I love it
great show it that's one where they did
it right and I think and hey god Bless
America baby I love that I love that
we're taking it to another level here
it's so funny though so the way you talk
about America is interesting to me
because you're like sort of like part of
the American Empire sort of not part of
the American Empire
how does Canada think of kit America
like is it like the Promised Land or
like this like that nah we don't really
care to come over there and like I feel
like I don't really care to come over
right now I've been like because all my
friends are in New York and I'm like
that's I'm gonna have an anxiety over
there it's too much I'm soft dude I can
go to LA Bombay in New York or two
cities that I'm like you can't live here
no way listen Matt Caan wouldn't survive
in New York for example and no no follow
or no disciple of Matt Kahn would
survive in New York it's too fast it's
too it'd be halfway to hailing a taxi
and run them over yeah New York is too
much
Canada's free Toronto's pretty chill a
candidate yeah it's it's interesting we
are living in in it's hard not to be
influenced by it we sound the same the
televisions the same so it's uh it is
the promised land though but i mighta -
diz I'll go when they call me listen the
Baba the laughing Baba they're gonna pay
for
my visa papers or maybe it's gonna be a
green card I don't know
I'm either gonna marry in some
Kickstarter's gonna pay for my shed
these guys are like we're to come over
yeah I worry that you're gonna start a
cult and to everyone in my audience when
a me starts sounding crazy when he
starts recruiting when he gets the email
list going don't sign up okay we gotta
get your we got to get to the bombshell
baby oh that's you told me there's a
bombshell I for the record I don't know
what this is I did not tell you yet go
ahead go ahead go ahead okay so you know
you're you're you had someone on you do
a little podcast with someone and you
guys were doing a bit of a you guys were
basically doing a wrap up on Brian rose
and what a psycho he is and you catch
someone on who I thought almost seems
almost like a morality expert and he was
there like that was like a moral pillar
in his community this is the channel
rebel wisdom behind I looked into his
stuff and like look he's got a course
it's fine it's got a little men's camp
okay
let's say he's a pyramid scheme the logo
is a pyramid I see something here maybe
there's something so I started watching
the the trailer everything just kept on
just sending me on more we were red
flags and hey guys tell me if I'm tell
me if I'm cocking it here I'm gonna be a
little [ __ ] over here
chucking around so I can from Canada but
I'm watching this guy's so the trailer
for the rebel wisdom Channel and the
first red flag is he's basically says he
used to be a journalist and then he he
ripped and dipped so hard that the BBC
said nah dude can't take it it's much
they ripped and dipped so hard but I
just gotta come back to my man was a big
ok ok I'm paraphrasing I'm paraphrasing
but he was big I guess he was kind of
saying like like you know maybe maybe he
was trying to go too hard on Hugh I
think he said he want to do more
in-depth content that's what he said in
the trailer so I want to go more
in-depth BBC third
spicy back it up you know safe they say
yeah hey you getting spicy back it up
right BBC BuzzFeed BC cuz your boys not
doing listicles he's doing full-length
whatever yeah he's doing like Doc's is
that he does dogs now that's the
interesting thing he has another
documentary called glitch in the matrix
documentary yeah
documentary it's it's honesty what
probably one of my favorite conspiracy
documentaries I've seen in a couple
years it's his music is good
cinematography beautiful filmmaker yeah
great filmmaker um I just it's not
journalism it might be a brainwash video
so here's the thing you guys are talking
with Brian Rose okay yours Frank O'Brien
Rose doc about freedom of speech
BBC grouping so I sort of watch this
guy's documentary glitch in the matrix
do you know what glitch in the matrix is
about I tell you real quick go ahead
please so Jordan Peterson which i think
is his the great guru ji to him I don't
know how you feel about during
Peterson's but I think that's their
spiritual leader here he got into a
debate with a feminist on BBC and just
like just later out I guess like yeah
won the debate so he made it this guy
made a documentary and the premise of
the documentary is the glitch in the
matrix is Jordan Peterson's it was it's
I guess I could call it like a moral
panic kind of documentary where he
basically did a documentary saying what
is her like what's wrong with like
basically if you think she won you're
part of the blue pill blue media the
blue church they called it he included
BBC and he put BBC in there to kind of
like David Rose where he's like if
anyone is so if you're a bright bright
bright nose he's like if you're part of
this thing your blue pills your little
[ __ ] a little beta [ __ ] you [ __ ]
cucking around lost your dick just a
bunch of feminists but if you're on the
red church to take the red pill now
you're a Peterson boy you know your
viagra your rock-hard so the dot so
that's the initial premise of it already
its documentary it's very heavily
opinionated and he seems like a nice guy
especially when he's on the show with
you very very cool got very like calm
and sober
yeah but I think it's a pretty extreme
opinion I don't know I don't know tell
me from being a [ __ ] over here but then
but the he had him put you interviews
and this is where look this
where I gotta give a little credit
because here's the thing with the BBC
you think of the beeps okay babes they
do this thing I love this okay cuz I
want to be called out
I love I finally I have I have a Baba to
call me out no no I'm not calling you
out I'm more like him I don't know he
look he's in a gray area we've talked
about a lot of people today no no an
action but but uh it's very interesting
because I think that while on the one
hand of course you're not a guilty for
who you associate with at the same time
I do think it's important to consider
who you associate with
but I'll say in London rabble wisdoms
defense as much as I could find out
about him at the time he seems like a
really son maybe he has a point of view
but he is a journalist he worked as a
journalist and whether or not he's
making opinionated pieces I mean what I
like about him is that he is at least
when you when I was watching his pieces
on Brian Rose they're very careful more
careful than I was I mean I contacted
Brian Rose four times he contacted him
six times
I gave Brian Rose like 48 or 24 hours to
respond my guess is this guy gave him
more time to respond he said okay
careful journalists and I really admired
I still admire that about him and I do
admire his filmmaking at least tight
regardless of his perspective what I I
think that he brings to the table
especially in that conversation is I was
very heated I was very like hot like
this guy he's a scam blah blah blah yeah
this guy was much more careful David
Fuller's a much more calculated and he
thinks about the broader issues beyond
just Brian Rose as an individual he's
talking about what's going on in the
culture in the culture that's creating
our need for this and he was talking
about like free speech
Brian Rose is playing this super
powerful if I can summarize his argument
Brian Rose is playing a really powerful
card with the freedom of speech card
that a lot of conservatives feel like
need to be played like Donald Trump when
he sent that tweet genius Twitter
because he played to a lot of
conservatives letting Jordan Peterson -
I think Jordan Peterson did the
book for this guy and and look roger
ailes was doing it before them and i
think conservatives have always done
this they [ __ ] with liberals they get
outraged and then these conservatives
they'll get outraged that they're
outraged
so it's that's a Ponzi scheme it's an
emotional Ponzi scheme where you're like
okay what are you mad about now cuz this
is a fox news is always been doing this
they put out like lit city this guy's
calling it blue church it's a okay
fox has been calling it liberal media
and it goes back to like there's this
communist agenda or like left-wing
agenda trying to take over our media and
they're trying to feminize this or
whatever but fox news has been doing it
forever trying excited cuz it was blue
church what's that they're trying to
[ __ ] us they're trying to [ __ ] us these
guys have dude the blue pill red pill
like as a piece of journalism
he opened the documentary saying if
you're on her team he did though he did
the polarizing thing he did the
us-against-them
he did the freedom of speech attack he
did like yeah like like whose team
you're on and then and then this again
the thing with the BBC and journalism is
that the Biebs I feel like they put out
documentaries I mean they'll have one
person saying like one opinion you know
I'm saying your boy father he just he
said the whole documentary one up dude
everyone same opinion every single
person he's like hey so what did you
think of their how would he it was this
questions were set up weird too but
every single person like the first guy
Jordan and I'm gonna I'm gonna have
what's it called uh not editorialize I'm
gonna paraphrase the [ __ ] out of this
cuz I'm a comic or whatever but the
first guy Green Hill he goes so what did
you think happened there and Green Hill
goes she came with lies and deceit and
it could not stand in front of the pure
light of truth that is the most high
Jordan Peterson and there was nothing
she could do and she was destroyed and
crushed our avid paraphrasing then he
listed the woman which is a bit of a
hack moved to be like hey you're a woman
what do you think it's like dude she's
your friend you already know it just
goes whatever I guess it's a documentary
so that's what I was doing the woman
said the woman said the one said
actually I think she was a disgrace on
all women and all feminism that day she
was such a disgrace like so she went
into another he and then he had on a
rebel wisdom camp counselor I guess an
elder or whatever he had a clip of
Jordan Peterson being like hey if I'm
debating with a man and he starts
talking [ __ ]
I'll drop them I'm skeptical of this I
mean it's in the matrix and she like
know if that guy was a guy I'm dead I'm
laying them oh dude I mean that's the
clue
we'll have to almost you know we should
do for next episode or maybe another
episode is like we should be like how
much of a Misha was just like going off
on tangents and how much was actually
close to this glitch in the matrix
already to meet the glitch in the matrix
is already he's setting it up like a
like a cinnamon splitting bed let me
look wants to go for this thing like the
deeper issue for a culture coming right
and you're saying let me summarize your
summary to really get to the heart of
this thing so he was saying that yeah
there's this there's this dominant
culture but then Jordan Peterson was too
powerful so then he cuts right through
like a knife through the culture is that
is that is that what it is I mean the
documentary I call it a documentary or
journalism it just felt a little bit
like okay you had one opinion you've
made a graphic to say this intense
opinion you interviewed a bunch of your
friends like there are arguments you can
make like one of the art like look I
don't want to just give writing those I
know it's a good thing to do one thing
you could do is you could talk about
when people are debating and this is an
old Greek philosophy and I think Jordan
penis is even talk about this when
you're debating if you won that just
means you won you knew how to debate
better like you knew how to use argument
like stuff whatever better rhetorically
rhetorical rhetorical stuff like so that
he never really talked about he kind of
skipped past that and just said hey why
do you think everyone's a beta me luck
now like that it was kind of like hey
why do you think some [ __ ] harpy
thinks she can talk [ __ ] to PD pops and
they all same opinion same so no other
side know cuz there are arguments in the
sense that like look I'm not gonna
pretend like she won the debate she's
not win the debate sure but we like like
there's it feels like a piece of
propaganda where you skip Pat where
where there's the fear-mongering the
more moralizing of like you're part of
the blue church you're part of this cult
or whatever if you're not agreeing with
her but also there's this thing of like
there's no other thing to talk about
here like he was bringing up arguments
she couldn't defend the arguments
because she's like I mean Peterson's a
good speaker man I mean he's a great
rhetorically he's incredible but they
didn't talk about any of that it's just
an hour long of one opinion and then
here's the thing now he's not doing the
hard clothes like these guys but he's
got the course and he's got the training
camp which is I guess it's fine I'm I
don't know I listen but the thing is is
that I think I've spoken to him and I
think he's very nice it is hard to just
yeah yeah he's like using it as like a
way to support his channel or whatever
like the course the thing is is the
course is like two hundred and fifty
dollars I'm not ever I'm not ever gonna
to note it but what's the camp
that's my question yeah I don't know but
here's the thing
I'm a cheers to things you pick your
battles everyone's got a frickin course
these days man I'm struggling out here
to find anybody who doesn't have a
course yeah look at the end of it it was
the first but I do feel unlike a lot of
the tactics that Brian Rose use the
playbook is from here but the dip but
the difference hold on hold on
and the difference is this my point
along this whole thing and I think
David's point is that he's using freedom
of speech disingenuously to siphon money
from his followers whereas we're whether
or not you agree with the freedom of
speech card from Jordan Peterson it is
meant genuinely and it is taken from a
place not like totally cynically to get
like siphon money from followers our our
point was that this platform that he's
like saying he wants to make it exists
and like the thing that he's talking
about he keeps lying to his followers he
keeps inventing new phases and it's
always like it's all about him it's not
about how do we create something for
people like me it's like I'll senator on
him so it's different but different
different yeah he does have he does of
course and I talked him about his
triangle that's one thing I'll tell you
I thought him got to get rid of the
triangle it's to the interview with Jen
Peterson and this is again like
journalism is so tough he at the end of
one of the interviews with him again
it's just I don't want to be rude but to
call it journalism like he
just setting him up with like it's it's
a grown man kind of jerk another man or
whatever professor we got the t-shirts
and he takes out and then the professor
actually doesn't expecially yes yes it's
a pyramid to represent the hierarchy
that must be followed but the Sun is in
the middle and that room it represents
the father I think they're brainwashed
look I love you David
I have nothing wrong with you I have
nothing wrong with you eyes like your
logo I do think you need to change it
though because it's too it's too much
well yeah cuz it's too much like the
Illuminati I saw it I was like it's this
guy in the Illuminati no let me actually
say though let me actually say in hey
like so some I was looking at when that
documentary was made is made in 2018
okay and I'm a big believer tell me what
you think about this okay have you ever
heard of the idea of thesis antithesis
synthesis uh tell me again because I've
heard this more of the ba ba side of
laughing mumbles okay this is great so
these so it's this idea that ideas come
along and they're in tension with each
other and they create something new and
then they become in tension again and I
sort of think about this I mean this is
actually I don't even want to say that
this is the philosophical idea because
I've kind of hijacked this idea and
created my own thing so this is just my
own thing okay basically I believe that
culture swings on pendulums and that
it's constantly sort of swinging between
like okay people kind of believe that
liberals have it right up people kind of
think that conservatives have been
wronged and they have it right and
there's like this like swinging and
there are always people on both sides
but like there's sort of this like tide
between the dominant like what the kind
of culture is thinking and I think at
that time it was a very specific time
with Jordan it was weird when Jordan
Peterson like took over the internet he
took over his channels dedicated to him
yeah defending him
like no I think what rebel wisdom a lot
of their early videos are like shouldn't
been talking [ __ ] like there's another
channel that's just like hey aren't you
bro Peterson don't talk [ __ ]
and the videos are like Jordan Peterson
destroys like feminist whatever and Dan
what's here's what's interesting though
now there's a bunch of videos countering
that and so he's like Jordan Peterson
was like countering this like dominant
ideology then Jordan Peterson for a time
sort of became very dominant in our
culture and then like there were a bunch
of people taking him down it's trust me
trust me they're gonna be a bunch of
people taking them down movements like
this they never last forever like they
just they come they serve their time to
correct whatever the imbalance was or
maybe not but and then something else
comes along and it's like that's the new
thing and then something on I think look
you gotta respect him for the come up
but I don't know if like I mean I get it
like he was trying to get back at some I
guess some feminists were canceling
people too much and that did get weird
for sure and then he made it like I must
do that I have to go back and fight
against them whatever my I guess my only
issues that is it I think there is this
anti-communist thing that he brings up a
lot which I know it's just been so
damaging in America especially where
it's like there's these communists come
in and it's this communist feminist
agenda it's destroying our culture it's
gonna turn the boys into [ __ ] and then
we're all gonna become communists so my
only issue with this narrative and it's
an old narrative this is why the
Americans are in every country we hear
about Vietnam okay and Everett Peterson
even talk about like oh there's these
guy they've been they've been protesting
the government's in the 70s too because
they're your whining hippies have you
seen these protests dude they're be it
offends me when I see a white person a
white kid get beat up it's like look
that's a lot okay I'm used to this
happening in other countries
70s I'm looking Chicago dude they're
dragging kids out of the university
because they're like you [ __ ] go
fight in Vietnam because communism is
coming and we're talking about that's
the one that damaged Americans so we
hear about Vietnam war very traumatizing
in Indonesia dude they straight up
killed 400,000 people because and what
really hurts me about that one
they weren't even communist they were
just a little liberal it was in the name
of communism they [ __ ] kill you dis
this we had a Salem witch moment with
I mean it's true look I know but listen
I'm CUBAN half-cuban
you know that a country last time I'm
never gonna stop repeating it so I have
a different perspective on this my
grandparents came fresh off the boat
they were they were like 20 21 25 I
forget their exact age but they
basically came over my grandpa one of
the last planes out and then it shut the
country down boom done Fidel forever
yeah okay
hated because they've seen what it did
they had a beautiful life they were they
got married they're about to start their
family they win over with a baby date so
they like had their whole life to
imagine you have your whole life
together
imagine someone takes over Canada
Canada's done everything you know about
Canada gone done boom Russians to
Eastern Europe - and we went to this
some has a bad record dude a bad rig
does have it has it does have a bad
record and but but I think the Americans
what they did is after World War two
they assumed that communism was going to
be as bad as Nazism and so they made
this military industrial complex to
permanently forever keep fighting it and
also they use that same rhetoric to just
ruin the health care system because the
health this is the other thing even in
America then it hurts you because you're
like well you can if you get health care
you're socialists now you're a commie so
this and I'm talking about like Vox as a
great peace will just help the ads hey
we're not about do don't like it that's
that's for babies dude in America in
America you're a [ __ ] if you need health
care dude I'm just kidding I'm obviously
joking but there's a little bit of there
is legitimately a little bit of that
vein in American like especially in
conservatism where it's sort of like hey
if you don't have no money to pay for
what are you doing he's at the
Republican convention and he and and
they're pressing him he's like a full
libertarian depressives like what if
someone's dying and they come to the
hospital and he what is gonna happen no
health care and Ron Paul goes well then
I guess he'll die and the crowd goes
yeah
[Music]
freedom baby freedom baby freedom to
live free to die that's it
yeah but but that communists care it's
interesting I mean it is hard to defend
it I'm nobody's communist still think
I'm not I'm not obviously never gonna
work I mean this is the thing to see
even in America there was people kind of
fight it be like hey how about we don't
go bankrupt on this literally conspiracy
that Moscow is back in Brazil and
Indonesia and today they take Vietnam
and Cambodia they're gonna come to
America but it is tough to argue with
the Castro thing because Castro's are
there Russia same thing Eastern Europe
so I don't want anyone to think that I'm
saying hey what's the big I mean also
yeah I think I think I think what you're
saying though I mean part of what you're
saying is we do have a little bit of us
like a slippery slope in us where if we
see anything that's close and we say
that's communism when it's not so it's
that's your point is that movie
propaganda on that side I find heavy
propaganda the anti Congress and then on
the right-wing team and again these guys
are worried about this there's a moral
panic of like today we'll do this and
then tomorrow communist I think Peters
will talk about goo legs Allah like
we'll end up in these like red lines
whatever but when I think about what
could destroy America I mean the
military's everywhere the Health Care's
[ __ ] these are this is all right wing
[ __ ] I'm not saying the Democrats don't
do it this is where I'm getting
political now I'm saying Republicans do
it by design I mean right concerns
everybody then and then the left they do
it because they're weak and spineless
and they just can't say no to the money
they gotta take the money at this point
I feel like everybody dead dude yeah I
mean they did go they did I feel like
they're a lot like both sides and this
is such a cliche thing so I'm gonna say
something to back up back and I'm
singing both side equivalencies no no
not both sides equivalency but they a
lot of the actions are the same and the
people who will do something different
who actually are ideologues and will
believe in something and like stand for
something they'll never get in you saw
that with Sanders dude Sanders I believe
would have done something different yeah
and he would and agree with him or not
he stood for what he stood for but guess
what dude out there's too much power
there's too much power consolidated
and though people are gonna keep it and
at a certain level I don't I don't think
it comes down to I'm a Republican I'm a
Democrat it's about money and I'm gonna
keep that money baby
yeah yo can I just say one more one more
[ __ ] Peter something that pissed me
off
Trump's getting elected this Peter
security says he's like Donald Trump
hey he's funny I don't know I maybe I'll
vote for him maybe I'll tell my boys I
don't know paraphrasing like [ __ ]
crazy I know but he said I don't know
maybe I'll vote for him
Trudeau in Canada we got Justin Trudeau
he appointed like a 50 percent female
thing and he did someone asked him on TV
and he's like this'll ruin everything
you'll destroy the whole country if you
put 50% because he pushed 50% women the
meritocracy the whatever Hey
Trudeau's doing all right man I mean he
call him a [ __ ] hey I'm gonna call him
blackface did you see how did you get
away with that I was stunned I guess I
thought them I thought the Liberals
would eat him on that because that's
what they do
some day same kind of like a little bit
like look he's dressing up like us He
loves us I don't give a [ __ ] I mean yeah
that's it that's a weird thing to though
where I'm like I understand blackface is
so wrong
wait but but how far back before it's
like that is there a statute of
limitations on dumb decisions and I'm
gonna say that knowing that's probably
get a lot of hate but listen Jimmy Jimmy
Kimmel Jimmy Kimmel 20 years 20 years
ago blackface they just put it up they
just put it up he's too big but you know
so Trudeau really paved the way for all
the black faces but my point is though
my point is though both cases they're
bringing up stuff from like 16 15 30
years ago I know that for me I would
feel like if you brought up what I did
five years ago it feel like dude I've
changed a lot and that's that's not me
trying to apologize for anything but
it's actually legit rue but especially
as you get older and older
if someone brings up something from when
you're like 20 come on things change and
like yeah I guess yeah I guess I guess
there was this there is this back and
forth thing every time I look at numbers
it just seems like the right wing is
kicking ass and the left what do they do
they go someone cancels I mean there's
such [ __ ] losers on the left like do
something that makes a difference right
like like they [ __ ] raised like all
of this they're like roger ailes does
this law to where he basically sets
these like like offending them traps so
there's a great foot shot where he has
like said what the Roger Ailes thing
I've never heard someone talk so much
about Roger Ailes I mean he's a terrible
person you know he is the king of media
he is like such a hair like like I feel
like I know you do the traditional scams
but we're talking like there's there's
these bombs like we're talking Fox he
was on a high level and Fox dude right
now Fox is selling gold please go ahead
dude he's dead
wait Fox lives on it lives on yeah he
lives on and nobody wants to advertise
with them because they're always talking
this [ __ ] [ __ ] so so they're doing
like a fat shaming bit Dov is like hey
we're not gonna put our real beauty
inside beauty on your your [ __ ] so now
you watch Fox it's just they're talking
about like what do you want Canadian
health care is garbage cuts a commercial
American freedom health care buy it now
it's to say like like even all them were
in gold companies cuz even Glenn begged
Bill O'Reilly they're like we have the
highest numbers her nobody wants to give
us money but I got I'm selling gold dude
honestly though if you're a company
maybe it's worth advertising on Fox the
cheap real estate he's just a backlash
from everybody else do you get cancelled
because you're advertising on Fox
they're pretty vicious and like look man
we're talking about vicious like again I
don't want to get I know it's a bummer
to get so political but like these guys
sold the Iraq war the Iraq arm is gonna
boy is talking about listening
economically trillion hey tell me hey
this is Texas I know it's Texas you're
like hey don't don't talk about the
military baby we go we get that money
ending country rather lose our
viewership okay hey hey no
gun talk imagine of all the stuff we say
I'm like why this I feel like we're so
much on both sides that we're gonna get
cancelled by both sides dude that's what
happened julian assange man julian
assange real a real shouldn't have been
talking [ __ ] moment for julian assange
so julia such puts out these iraq logs
it's all this illegal [ __ ] that that the
the americans did in iraq during their
occupation which was [ __ ] meat well
waste money but it even they did a bunch
of illegal [ __ ] but he puts it out with
new york times with all these big
journalists Pompeo is like I'm gonna
[ __ ] kill you you little [ __ ] Pompeii
was like the head of like the militant I
guess the military whatever but he's
basically like you're gonna die in jail
julian assange go [ __ ] yourself now at
the time before the left-wing people
were helping him out then during the
Hillary campaign he [ __ ] Hillary so
now the lefty said [ __ ] him he's gonna
die now he's gonna die yeah yeah he's
dying he's dying 23 hours a day he's a
nice he's like like isolation that is
what he did wrong isn't it because when
I look at what he did I think to myself
oh he exposed but his problem was he
exposed both sides you lead that's wise
you need to be polarized is because you
need allies you name it not enemies you
need allies wisdom baby even though he's
those viewers over and then you can you
and then we'll start talking I mean it's
not you bet look I'm not calling him a
Brian Rose obviously yes yeah he's he's
not he's not he's got a point of view
but look I don't know I like people with
points of view you have a point of view
I love it I don't share your point of
view I don't share his point of view
which none of it's fine it's fine
everyone's different everyone's got
their own thing
Hey look come on laughing Baba
hard-hitting questions baby we coming up
with lovingkindness
uh he drew a circle to keep me out yeah
I drew a bigger circle and I pulled him
in y'all and do the Crowder's
tell Joe hey I don't feel like give me
to come to Texas really do I have family
over there by
house get you a house freak okay well we
have gone deep sued we've gone deep I'm
anyone who's still here let's talk to
those guys first of all appreciate you
thank you second of all not you I was
appreciating them okay hey the people
the two people who are still here love
you guys
tell us in the comments below if you
have a guru you'd like us to talk about
yes hit us up with some topics please
we're dying for topics over here we're
gonna try to make this I'm feeling it
may be that we feel like we have to do
this every week but I'd be fine also
doing it maybe bi-weekly it depends how
many influencers you have lined out the
door your collaborative and by the way I
love that you go hey tell me if they do
you have a hundred thousand followers
yes or no I don't you're already trying
to go be a stepping like do like I Billy
dude I'm telling you I'm just here to
witness the birth of a star baby
hey hey hey you say that hey when they
hit that when you hit that five hundred
thousand mark oh when you hit that to
come but you're growing with me I'm
growing with you baby right like I mean
if I do that that's right come in that's
right we come to copy no I love it baby
collab collab the world away hey
appreciate you coming on the show
appreciate the audience and yeah thanks
for watching guys thanks for sticking
with us
we'll see you next time you can use you
charges
but she got a tough sell but you can use
your horn with me I know tell me
you can burn out all the stars in the
sea
but you won't ever get your papers on me
freakin see me to your family tree she
won't ever get your papers on me